aussitôt isolée aussitôt controversé la
série intitulée
ou à l'aube de notre histoire a été
lancé en novembre dernier sur Netflix à
travers les 8 épisodes on y suit la
quête du journaliste britannique Graham
Hancock prouvé qu'il y a 12000 ans une
civilisation très avancée et parvenu à
influencer les suivantes avant d'être
anéantie par un cataclysme tout ça sans
laisser de trace à l'exception bien sûr
de celle que Hancock prétend nous
dévoiler le fait que le géant Netflix se
présente le tout comme étant une série
documentaire a provoqué l'indignation
des archéologues qui voient plutôt un
cas de fumisterie qui recèle certains
des procédés associés à la pseudo
science
Salut bonjour bienvenue chez nous
descripteurs merci parlons d'abord du
fond des choses cette histoire là les
thèses avancées dans cette série Netflix
en quoi ça pose problème sur le plan
scientifique archéologique
anthropologique quand vous avez vu ça en
tant que scientifique j'imagine votre
réaction était immédiatement assez oui
donc ça brusque pas mal des sensibilités
qu'on a en tant scientifique surtout
quand on travaille sur ces périodes là
parce que ça prétend l'existence d'une
civilisation par laquelle on a
strictement aucune preuve donc déjà d'un
point de vue scientifique d'un point de
vue empirique il y a vraiment pas
beaucoup de chair sur laquelle marcher
et ça va vraiment à l'encontre de
décennies de travail qu'on fait en
archéologie je m'appelle Graham Hancock
je ne prétends pas être archéologue aux
scientifiques
je suis journaliste et j'enquête sur le
sujet de la préhistoire humaine
parmi les vérités qui dévoilent
qu'est-ce qui pose problème qu'est-ce
que des exemples qu'on peut se servir
pour montrer à quel point c'est basé sur
rien en gros ce qui fait c'est ce qu'on
appelle du Thierry picking ou de la
sélection de données il se promène d'un
site à l'autre comme ça pour trouver des
exemples de choses qui se ressemblent
vaguement lorsqu'on les compare d'un
point de vue extérieur ensuite c'est une
technique qui a pas vraiment de
fondement scientifique ce qu'on veut
qu'on fait une synthèse archéologique
c'est de prendre en considération
l'ensemble des données à partir du
moment où on écarte des données qui font
pas notre affaire mais on est dans un
registre qui a rien à voir avec une
approche scientifique à l'archéologie
comme par exemple en Turquie il y a un
site archéologique dont il parle
beaucoup c'est un excellent exemple on
parle du site de gobécli TP qui est un
site qui a été révolutionnaire lorsqu'il
a été découvert dans les années 90 ou
fuyez dans les années 90 c'est un site
où on voit certaines des premières
traces de construction permanente les
prémices de la sédentarisation et ce
qu'on voit c'est que ce sont des
chasseurs cue qui ont érigé ces
monuments là ces temples et que c'est
vraiment le symbolique si on veut le
rituel le rassemblement qui a été un
une des grandes impulsions derrière la
sédentarisation et le développement de
l'agriculture et c'est quelque chose
qu'on a pris quand dans la communauté
archéologique donc ensuite il y a un
tour de passe-passe que un coq fait qui
est de dire ah oui mais les archéologues
vous parleront jamais de ces 7 là mais
ce qui fait en fait c'est que il
présente une toute petite fraction de
ces sites-là qui ont été fouillées par
des archéologues qui ont été publiés par
des archéologues et il sélectionne ce
petit morceau là pour l'insérer dans sa
trame narrative sans qu'on est vraiment
l'ensemble des données qui sont connues
sur ce site là où les environs et c'est
vraiment ça on décontextualise dans le
fond l'information archéologique pour
fabuler vraiment et puis le fardeau de
la preuve il revient à vous c'est son
message à vous expert officiel de
prouver qu'il a tort c'est exactement et
ça c'est une technique ce dos
scientifique classique on affirme
quelque chose de grandiose démesuré en
termes de sa portée scientifique et on
dit ensuite que c'est le travail des
autres scientifiques contre lesquels en
série nous démontrer qu'ils ont tort
dans le fond et alors c'est pas vraiment
un travail scientifique on devrait
soutenir une conclusion essayer
d'invalider une hypothèse de travail
alors qu'ici c'est tout le contraire on
cherche des morceaux d'information qui
vont soutenir une conclusion avec
laquelle on parle déjà donc c'est
vraiment la science renversée
complètement
qu'il n'est pas scientifique et qu'il
est journaliste or dans son dans sa
Syrie il y a des experts en quelque
sorte qui sont interviews et qui
l'accompagne dans sa démarche qu'est-ce
qu'on peut dire sur ces expertises là
donc ici c'est il y a deux choses à
comprendre par rapport à l'expertise sur
laquelle il s'appuie dans un
généralement c'est un expert auquel il
va faire référence alors que
généralement dans une perspective plus
largement journalistique on va chercher
plusieurs experts qui vont soutenir
l'information qu'on présente avec des
points de vue contraire exactement si le
public curieux fait un peu de recherche
sur internet mais on se rend compte
qu'effectivement c'est un professeur
dans une université britannique mais
c'est un professeur en génie donc
quelqu'un qui a aucune base en
archéologie donc on fait référence à une
expertise on utilise les titres on fait
référence à
la terminologie scientifique mais la
vraie expertise est complètement
escamotée ici alors on est en face
finalement d'un produit qui prétend
avancer une thèse qui n'a pas de banc
scientifique or Netflix a choisi de
mettre ça en ligne dans la catégorie
documentaire et c'est là que vous entrez
en scène vous et d'autres membres de la
communauté archéologique dans le monde
pourquoi ça pose problème ça pose
problème parce que dans le fond avec
l'étiquette documentaire et surtout avec
la portée que Netflix commedia c'est que
on a la tendance à prendre ça pour
acquis on se dit Netflix qui rejoint un
public
énorme de par le monde faut avoir au
moins fait un peu de travail pour
s'assurer de la qualité de l'information
qui est véhiculé dans cette émission là
et en prétendant que ces documentaires
ça induit déjà en erreur en public qui
est friand d'histoire qui est friand de
connaissance sur le passé humain et ici
c'est ça qui est un peu dommage on a des
moyens considérables qui sont investis
dans une série de valeurs tout à fait
questionnable alors que je pense qu'il y
a énormément de travail archéologiques
hyper intéressant qui pourrait être
présenté pour une fraction du prix et
c'est pas le cas en fait on se fait
servir des idées que au final en coque
recense depuis 30 ans là c'est pas des
nouvelles idées et dans sa trame
mondiale vous scientifiques mainstream
empêcher les gens de voir les faits tels
qu'ils sont or si vous je dirais
Salvatori vous découvrez avec preuve à
l'appui
confirmé par d'autres éléments qui
s'agit bel et bien d'une civilisation
ancienne ultra avancée ça c'est une
réjouissance pour vous vous allez tout
sauf le cacher non exactement si on
trouvait des preuves d'une civilisation
très antique ça serait un coût énorme
notre réputation serait assurée on
passerait dans le firmament des
archéologues pour toujours et en fait il
y a aucune raison de pas dévoiler
dévoiler quelque chose de cette grandeur
mais plus que ça je pense que c'est
aussi l'idée que
l'idée de base c'est que il prétend
qu'on le sait et qu'on le cache donc il
y a aussi mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on
ferait ça et pourquoi comment est-ce
qu'on réussirait à embarquer toute la
communauté archéologique là-dessus je
veux dire à un moment donné ça va en
prendre des photos compromettantes tous
les archéologues à travers le monde pour
leur dire de faire ce qu'on veut qu'il
fasse et on a juste pas ce levier là
vraiment je vous assure
mais si supposons quelqu'un vous dit oui
mais professeurs réel Salvatore et c'est
du divertissement c'est pas grave
qu'est-ce que vous répondez mais je suis
d'accord je suis d'accord c'est du
divertissement le danger ici c'est que
on le présente pas comme du
divertissement on le présente comme un
documentaire ensuite c'est que c'est
problématiques parce que ça crée un
climat ou ça nourrit un climat ou
la méfiance envers disons la science
officielle envers le discours officiel
ces graines ou s'effrites à force de
toujours se faire dire faut pas s'en
formaliser c'est pas grave parce que
justement toutes les hypothèses sont
égales toutes les idées sont égales et
ici on utilise des mots c'est du
scientifique si on veut on utilise la
terminologie scientifique mais pour
parler de choses qui sont pas vraiment
des hypothèses de recherche on dit moi
j'ai une hypothèse dans le sens que j'ai
une idée mais une hypothèse scientifique
c'est la base d'un travail c'est quelque
chose qui est testable qu'on peut
invalider c'est pas ça qui est présenté
du tout ici